we had one friend died a year for like
ten years
it qualified people because that was a
dangerous profession and we did it every
day fly in space once every six or seven
years so at least the frequency of risk
is lower but when we look back now to
what the risk was on my first shuttle
launch the risk of death during ascent
was about one in 38 we thought it was a
lot better than that but now learning
everything we knew it was extremely
risky thing to do but you just you go
okay this is gonna be risky but it's
worth it now my job is to not die doing
this
how can we spend the next three years
learning so much about this that no
matter what happens we have a plan we're
gonna react so that we improve our odds
of surviving so Mike yeah most dangerous
thing you encountered launching into
space was pretty scary well a brief fly
past you or Union I never saw any debris
come at us but there was evidence of it
like for example on the Hubble you can
see this out the Air and Space Museum we
pulled out the wide field camera and
wide field camera has an exposed
radiator on it and when I first saw it
and when it went back on earth it was
peppered with little holes so these are
micro meteoroids meteorite wasn't yeah
they cratered it they didn't while your
space walking you could get hit by
something here on the why wouldn't you
always be hit by something because it
doesn't it's not constantly coming at
the same place it's not like a rainstorm
constantly right but every once in a
while something will come did it scare
you
no yes talked about it a lot about what
might happen we took you take
precautions you practice rescuing each
other you go through your training and
understand what that risk is but when
you're out there you don't wanna be
worried about getting hit by a rock no
worry about doing your job and okay so
yeah you knew it intellectually but you
feel it emotionally no cuz you have to
get the job done okay right Chris
Hatfield was in the space station for
five months and he recorded a video that
went viral and it's the first music
video from space let's check it out
[Music]
control to me
you really
[Music]
want to know
shoots you
[Music]
it's time to guide the
whew
so that was a sample from his whole
video yeah where it's it's Space Oddity
yeah by David Bowie right and if you
listen to the words of that I mean it's
quite compelling and it's and I
remembered hearing that and I said this
is an artist singing about a future we
don't have yet right and I that was sort
of a force operating on culture that I
hoped would have continued and that we'd
all be on Mars today yeah what I wanted
to know from them is how the hell did he
get a frickin guitar in space ya did
that cuz it's a really good guitar
though let's find out how does this man
get this guitar in space the NASA
psychiatrists and psychologists put the
guitar on board because there's always
been guitars on Space Station's the
Russians had went on sell you then they
had it on mir i brought a guitar Tamir
in 1995 but human guitar in in space for
decades I've been a musician my whole
life but when I got to the International
Space Station
they had already put a guitar up there
they brought it up on the shuttle in the
summer of a1 and so it's been up there
for 13 or 14 years and it's just a
little guitar and to fit you know it's a
parlor sized guitar but it's a good one
and it gets played pretty much every
night you know there's lots astronauts
or musicians really it's really nice to
help I gotta hand it to you that's you
know you picked the right song for that
as soon as people heard there was a
musician in the space station there was
this social media clamoring for me you
gotta cover Space Oddity
and I was thinking I know covers Bowie
why would I ever do that besides the
astronaut dies at the end of the song
you know that's right but my son said
you've got to everyone really you don't
do it for everybody else not for you and
I got him to rewrite the words so that
the astronaut lived at the end
you